touchdevelop is a touch-centric
programming environment on the windows
phone targeting end-users it provides
API abstraction over the phone's data
and sensors in touchdevelop
people program via touch let me show how
people create a script that posts a
random photo to the screen in
touchdevelop first I create a command to
retrieve a random picture I navigate
over all the choices to select a random
picture from my collection and save it
to a variable next I need to post the
picture to the screen I select the
variable pic that I just created and
select post to wall now the script is
done and I can run it directly on my
phone what I show next is how to achieve
the same thing in our synthesizer I
invoke the synthesizer by hitting the
search button and type in say post photo
the synthesizer Maps the query to touch
develops api's and synthesizes
additional code to combine the mapped
api's into code snippets since there
might be multiple interpretations of the
query the synthesizer ranks the
synthesize snippets and presents only
the top choices I can select the top one
to insert it into my script and I get
the exact same script that I created a
moment ago let's move on to another
example say I want to play a song the
intended script is at the top choice or
I want to check if I can access my
current location extracting its nearest
address and post to the screen I can
also give the key words in a different
order like describe current location
and I can send this via SMS to my friend
whose phone number I've just typed in
in this next example I want to tint a
random photo since I did not specify the
tinted color the synthesizer uses the
default color which is sepia however if
I put in a color for example blue it
will use it immediately now I can save
the blue tinted picture to the library
in this example I want to take a picture
and save it to the library
how about drawing some text on the
picture that I've just taken
for example touchdevelop is so cool
in black
and save it to the library
I can also draw the current location to
the picture
in a random color note that the system
is smart enough to infer the conversion
from location to string automatically it
gives feedback to the users on words or
phrases that it does not understand
suppose I enter the color pink and
touchdevelop does not have any matching
API then the synthesizer ignores this
word and performs the mapping with the
remaining words the synthesizer also
synthesizes code that is relevant to the
current program context in this new
script I have a global variable n of
type number and a function fib oh that
takes a number and returns a number in
the main function I have two local
variables X and sum now I want to call
the function fib o with ten
or with the global variable n
or with n plus 10 the synthesizer
presents the two most likely options
since X is a float number
I'm a round it perhaps to three digits
or I can round it and pass it to fib ah
the synthesizer is capable of
synthesizing conditionals for example if
I want to check if the media player is
playing and if this is the case posit
or if it is currently paused resume the
player
the synthesizer can also generate loops
including nested loops
next I will show how to create a loop
that iterates ten times adding the
indices to the variable sum
note that there are two interpretations
in this example the intended one is
shown at the top in the second snippet
the synthesizer generates a temporary
variable for the addition operation
which the user could use later on as the
final example let us combine the tinted
pink sure example that I've shown
earlier with the loop
here is the synthesized snippet it
iterates 15 times each time it tints a
random picture with a random color and
posts it to the screen now we can run it
on the phone